how do you train someone to believe that
their success is inevitable
i drill it in them a hundred times until
we believe it
i think that whenever you're trying to
take on a new belief
sometimes our subconscious mind needs
proof and so
i try to tell people what that means in
tangible terms like why
is your success inevitable and
what will happen if you don't believe
your success is inevitable
right like if you don't believe your
success is inevitable
it is very likely that you have a plan b
you know that you have some sort of
backup plan that you have
set up a timeline for yourself where if
this doesn't happen in five years i'm
gonna move back home or i'm gonna do
something else
um right you're coming up with like
insurance because you don't believe a
hundred percent it's like a prenup for
your dream
because you don't believe 100 that it's
going to work out and
what happens is that when you don't
believe your success is inevitable
you don't take the big risks you don't
put yourself out there in the same way
because you don't
believe that it can happen right so it
really impacts the strategy or the
actions that you end up
taking so i try to help people by
showing them
where you know where their current
belief of not believing their success is
inevitable is leading them
and how that's playing out and i like to
inspire people to show them like
why i think their success is inevitable
and i think that if you can take away
the lottery
feel of succeeding right because i think
that you'll hear often
oh succeeding in hollywood that's like
winning the lottery
so for example one of my clients i think
this is in my book
she said that that was something that
she had heard a lot you know that
good luck trying to make it in hollywood
that's like winning the lottery
and so i said to her can you count on
your hand can you name
any people you know who have won the
lottery
and she was like you know i don't think
i know anyone who's won the lottery
i said okay now can you count on your
hand and name me people
who have succeeded in hollywood
and she listed like 10 people that she
personally knew who were doing well in
the industry
and so you know because we want to give
our subconscious
brain the subconscious part of our mind
some sort of tangible proof to hold on
to and so when we go through that it's
like oh okay so it's actually not as
hard as winning the lottery
it's not that random because i i can
name so many more people that
have succeeded right so suddenly your
subconscious goes oh okay that's
different
so we start looking for proof of why
like why is your success inevitable like
why is it inevitable that you will
succeed
well if you take a look at you know all
the people who are
successful and who are you know if we
take a look at their actions or
everything that they've done
and if you're doing the same things it
is inevitable that it will lead to
success and that success might look
different
to every person and however you define
success
but um you know i really try to help
people
retrain their brain to understand that
succeeding in hollywood doesn't have to
be this
insane unlikely thing
you know i think that we kind of come
into it with that notion
and so we want to train our brain to
understand that that's not actually true
do you think some people might want to
fail because it brings more sympathy
more people like you
if too successful people won't like you
i that's an interesting question i've
never thought of it that way i think a
lot
of people want to fail because
if their subconscious mind does not
believe that they can succeed
if they fail they're proving it right
and people like to be right
so they like to say see told you i
couldn't succeed
right and so like i always used to give
this example sorry i'm giving so many
actor examples i work with a lot of
actors but
um you know if you
don't believe that you 100 are going to
succeed as an actor
you might take a day job that is a nine
to five
and if you have a nine to five day job
you can't really audition i guess now
it's a little different during the
pandemic with self tapes everything self
tapes right now
but you know pre pandemic and hopefully
post pandemic
auditions will be in person again and
they're going to be during the day
during the week right and so if you have
a nine to five job
you're taking this on because you think
you're doing the responsible thing
and we could talk about day jobs is like
a whole other conversation where we can
have where
a lot of people have an idea in their
mind that the only way
to financially support themselves is
through nine to five work
um but that's like a self-sabotaging
move right
and so then you're not getting auditions
because you can't
go on them unless you're calling out for
a doctor's appointment every day
and then you end up you know a couple
years in and you're not succeeding in
hollywood and then you can go
see i was right i'm not succeeding in
this town in this industry
so i think that um
people self-sabotage just to like prove
their subconscious
mind right um but there's there's so
many
reasons why people want to fail that
some people are afraid of success
they're afraid you know kind of what
you're talking about are they afraid of
like not being liked but also
what does that mean in the dynamics of
your family you know
what will your family think if you
succeed what does that look like
um you know
how will you feel if you're quote
unquote more successful than your
parents or you know someone that raised
you or something you know people
struggle with so many
nuanced things about failing and
succeeding so i think there are many
reasons but those are a few
right or or maybe if um the
the brother or the sister was always the
golden
child and then the black sheep actually
surpasses it yes
that that's a taboo no it's not okay
yeah there's that's interesting people
will be afraid of success like
that because we would think oh no no
that will not i'm that wouldn't happen
to me no i just
you know yeah and some people think that
if i do succeed there are other things
in life i won't be able to have
you know like if i'm successful in
hollywood i won't be able to have
um a happy marriage and raise kids you
know people have that fear sometimes of
like you know the scheduling with
hollywood that i won't be able to
have a family things like that so
sometimes people self-sabotage because
they're afraid that
even if they do succeed there are other
things that they won't
be able to have or that it'll you know
negatively impact relationships
that's true or the nanny will know my
kids better than right yeah
what are some examples of star qualities
star qualities
i think one of the things that i outline
i have a whole chapter called star power
chapter two
one of the examples that i give in the
book is when you think about
someone who is a star like taylor swift
or steven spielberg right so it's not
even necessarily a star as in
they're a performer and they're in front
of the camera someone that's a star
in their industry who were they
before they had any credits
who was taylor swift before anybody knew
her name she was taylor swift
right and so i think it's about how you
show up in the beginning
and i talk about you know like we all
have this greatness within us and you
don't need a resume
or an imdb credit or any other kind of
validation
to prove that you can be a star you know
that you
have greatness i think that we all have
greatness already
within us and so you know star power is
about
embracing that connecting to your own
star power that you have before a single
person knows your name or before you
have
anything on your resume you can still
have that star power
but it's about showing up as a star now
before waiting for somebody else to
validate you and to say that you
are a star or to say that you are great
um
it's about believing that in yourself
now
before you do anything can you give me
example of a star quality that seems
that's kind of unknown that would be
unlikely that you would never think that
you know we think of someone with just
amazing confidence owns a room
head turner in so many ways um
charming i think that
for me it's it's not even about
necessarily those things it's a
well the confidence piece it's about the
it's about owning your dream
owning what you want and deciding you
are worthy of it
because that will translate to
risks that you take in actions you take
the example i give in my book is about
steven spielberg
and about his story about how he you
know
basically broke in he was able to get a
meeting
on the universal studios lot with chuck
silvers who i think was working
in post and he got to connect with him
for three days
and he was so excited he got to be on
the lot and i think he got to show him
like a short film he had made or
something like that
and chuck said okay well the three days
are up you know
i can't get a pass for you to come back
onto the lot you know
if you want to come back you'll have to
kind of find your own way
i can't get you like a permanent pass so
steven spielberg was like all right i
need to get back on this lot
i need to connect with these people i
need to show them my work i need to get
in front of them
so the next day he shows up in a suit
holding a briefcase goes up to the gate
and just waves to the guy at the gate
and it looks like you know he has the
appearance of working there
and they just let him in he didn't have
to show a badge that would probably not
happen today
because you really do need to have a
drive on today
but what i love so much about that story
is that
he was taking a risk and being
incredibly bold
to try to create opportunity for himself
and he didn't wait until he had jaws on
his resume to feel confident enough to
do that you know he didn't wait until
he was the steven spielberg that we know
because i think it's easy for people to
go
oh he's steven spielberg he can do that
but he wasn't that steven spielberg that
we know
when he did that so for me it's examples
like that it's like how do you show up
in the beginning do you
show up and take bold risks you know
showing up like you are
the star now you don't have to wait
until someone else deems you a star
to to take those kinds of risks and
and take those actions i like that so
sorry again it's knowing that
start like owning your dream and saying
that i am worthy of it
yes and and when you feel that way
what risks do you end up taking like you
know what i mean i think that a lot of
people in steven spielberg's position
would never do something like that
until they are at his now known level of
success
right somebody won't feel comfortable
taking that big of a risk
unless they already felt validated by
hollywood you know like one time
nothing ever really came of it but there
was
some tv show filming near where i on
location near where i lived
and i saw the prop truck and it was open
and so i brought my business cards to
the prop truck
and there was no one there and i just
left my business cards on the floor of
the prop truck
you know so it's like it's like things
like that it's like how how do you show
up like
can you be bold and show up in a way
that most people would never do unless
they
already felt validated by the industry
that's a great story yeah i heard about
someone else who had a business card and
they were mad and they were in real
estate and they're just like forget this
and they threw them
all in a parking lot and someone found
one and said
i have a house to list amazing right
yeah you know look
i mean like not every bold risk is going
to be received with open arms but
if you're not taking those risks you're
never going to get the potential
opportunities that could come from them
right
right because you know this is a town
where you know there's
all these pretty people and and they're
accolades and and people are bragging
and and they don't want to stay small
they want to just kind of like
peacock feathers and i think it's easy
to be in a room
whatever your thing is and and hear that
from the side
and you're like i i what am i doing here
you know and then but i like what you're
saying that
if you just all you have to do is just
say i'm owning
this is what i want to do and i'm worthy
of it and it doesn't matter if this
person
you know has this beautiful plumage that
they're kind of showing the world
my thing is also going to matter you
have the plumage too it's just not
visible yet like i i really believe that
we all have that greatness inside of us
i think it's internal
i think you know the plumage that you're
talking about comes from like external
you know imdb credits or you know
prestige or celebrity or whatever but to
me it's a hundred percent an internal
thing it has nothing to do
with the external and you can have all
those external things and still show up
and feel imposter syndrome
you know and not feel worthy of being in
the room that you're in and
and that happens you know all the time
too look at you know
child stars you know a lot of times
where it doesn't
it doesn't pan out as they get older
because it's like too much too soon they
weren't ready for it mentally
right and so maybe they felt like an
imposter or whatever there's a million
different
reasons why that happens but it's like
you know 75 of lottery winners end up
getting going broke
and again it's like this whole idea of
like they weren't internally ready
for the thing so to me that plumage that
you speak of
is really truly internal and not
external
you